ya hemos visto la ley de parada y con
cierto detalle noten que si tenemos un
circuito hecho con un conductor y
tenemos un cambio de flujo magnético
entre un cambio en el tiempo a través de
la superficie definida por este circuito
nos va a inducir una fuerza
electromotriz a través de este circuito
lo que a su vez ocasionará una corriente
que comenzará a circular a través de
este circuito y esta corriente va a
depender de la resistencia que tenga
este conductor hay muchas formas que
hemos visto en las que se puede dar un
cambio en el flujo magnético una vez que
podemos tener un cambio en el campo
magnético puede ser un cambio en su
magnitud o en su orientación podemos
tener un cambio en la forma del circuito
al conductor si aumenta o disminuye va a
tener un cambio en el flujo recuerden
que el flujo es el componente del campo
magnético que es perpendicular a la
superficie es el promedio de esto
multiplicado por el área de esta
superficie
y otra forma que vamos a estudiar en
este vídeo es inducir una fuerza
electromotriz al cambiar no la forma del
circuito
ni tampoco cambiando el campo magnético
sino cambiando la orientación del
circuito en particular vamos a rotar
este circuito
pensemos en esto aquí tengo este
circuito que está rotando en este eje y
lo voy a rotar en sentido horario a
través de este campo magnético constante
puedes saber que es constante porque
todos los vectores que muestreado aquí
tienen la misma dirección y les he
dibujado la misma magnitud
tenemos que ver que conforme rotamos el
circuito el ángulo que se va a formar
entre la superficie y el campo magnético
va a cambiar y en este punto conforme lo
estamos rotando en sentido horario el
componente del campo magnético que es
perpendicular a la superficie va a
aumentar a qué me refiero con esto vamos
a verlo desde el punto de vista del
circuito desde este punto de vista
nuestro campo magnético tiene cierto
ángulo vamos a tratar de dibujar el
ángulo aquí cualquiera que éste sea y
conforme vamos rotando lo todo el
circuito que está sostenido en este eje
si lo muevo en sentido horario que va a
pasar con este ángulo si nos imaginamos
que esto lo estamos rotando con una
rapidez constante vamos a tener que
ahorita rotamos el circuito y ahora el
campo magnético se ve así
así que el componente que es
perpendicular a la superficie está
aumentando pasa de algo así
o algo así
así que al menos para este punto de la
rotación hasta que lleguemos al punto en
el que quede plano hasta que lleguemos
al punto en el que quede horizontal el
componente de nuestro campo magnético
que es perpendicular a la superficie va
a aumentar por lo que tendremos un
incremento en el flujo magnético durante
ese tiempo así que si tenemos un
incremento en el flujo magnético
durante este tiempo hasta llegar a la
posición horizontal que es lo que va a
pasar
pues tendremos una corriente inducida y
ahora vamos a pensar cuál es la
orientación de esa corriente
queremos una corriente que induzca un
campo magnético que vaya en sentido
contrario al de nuestro cambio en el
flujo si para esta rotación nuestro
flujo se está incrementando o está
aumentando hacia arriba
al menos desde el punto de vista de este
circuito pues se va a crear un campo
magnético que vaya en la dirección
opuesta se va a inducir una corriente
que a su vez va a inducir un campo
magnético cuya dirección es contraria u
opuesta al cambio del flujo original que
corriente nos genera un campo magnético
de este tipo pues usamos nuestra regla
de la mano derecha
mis dedos deben de señalar la dirección
del campo magnético por lo que mi pulgar
de la mano derecha va indica la
dirección de la corriente inducida por
lo que esta va a ser la dirección de
esta corriente inducida
y por lo que estoy mostrándoles todo
esto es para que vean que hay varias
formas de tener un cambio en el flujo
magnético y por lo tanto hay varias
maneras de inducir una corriente y esta
es particularmente interesante porque
puedo implementar una rotación mecánica
y generar una corriente inducida y este
principio básico aunque no se usa un
circuito tan básico como este es
exactamente cómo funcionan los
generadores eléctricos que podríamos
verlo como lo inverso de un motor
eléctrico en un motor eléctrico tenemos
una corriente que es lo que ocasiona el
movimiento de rotación en cambio aquí
tenemos algo que está rotando y que me
va a ocasionar que se forme una
corriente
y esto es lo que sucede cuando vemos
algo como esto cuando vemos molinos o
plantas hidroeléctricas en este molino
las aspas van a estar girando y aquí
adentro vamos a tener una versión un
poquito más sofisticada de esto de aquí
que va a estar rotando y que va a
inducir una corriente eléctrica claro el
campo magnético no va a ser exactamente
como éste va a tener un mecanismo más
sofisticado pero es el mismo principio
básico es la ley de faraday en acción lo
mismo con las plantas hidroeléctricas
tenemos la energía potencial de la caída
del agua que está fluyendo para darle
vueltas a un eje que nos va a ayudar a
generar la corriente eléctrica
usando exactamente este principio